chagum raise money welcome back to Dark
Souls 2
I bought the game when it came out but I
just been too busy to actually play it
so I'm so damn excited to give it a go
I'm not even gonna keep talking so yeah
now I can play online and get rekt by
other people that's great
I don't like this hello oh [ __ ] what are
there don't touch me I'm famous who
lives here
what is your name so I get the answer my
name oh my god Terry Mike swag number 2
please don't be hurt it please don't be
hurt ed so now I get this like what is
deprived on cloth origin unknown and you
know what [ __ ] it under Prime okay I get
it I get it I think it's funny because
I'm not wearing clothes I make you look
saggy as [ __ ] naked - shut up so we're
playing deprived and apparently I look
like a woman for some good job great
creation fire chick born June just good
my god I'm dashing I'm dashing ha hobo's
tell him ugly ugly backstabbed with a
fist alright so far no dying and a lot
of sexiness move camera if you didn't
figure this out by now I'm worried about
you
party night hey that's not what you did
in the first game what the hell you
yeah bra god that's disgusting
I became as A&B okay well I guess we're
gonna have to deal with being ugly as
[ __ ] now now for [ __ ] sake I need to
jump here [ __ ] that the camera is so
sensitive
I'll come swear to god there's no
[ __ ] way I'm gonna Mabel
job you idiot I can I swear to god I'm
the only one who get stuck at the
[ __ ] tutorial okay you [ __ ]
jump oh my god I'm the best player in
the world another herb I died all this
time for another herb how am I gonna
jump back
oh god okay why did they gotta change it
it's not it's like he doesn't even try
to swim just like adds water I better
just [ __ ] die we can do this oh you
you can't be seen
yes we can hearing I finish Dark Souls
okay um I'm not supposed to be this bad
so now lose all my hair and no one will
date me
ah you little [ __ ] you can't even get up
here can you you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
jelly of my hair don't you bet bet you
wish you had hair like this yeah little
bit
okay don't don't look at me letting that
pose that's creepy okay night now you're
freaking me out okay now I'm gonna have
to watch [ __ ] you up [ __ ] lucky I flash
you a copy for disrespecting me never
jump down in holes that goes for a real
life Tim Russ unless there's like a free
cookie
the whole sign which I doubt there is
because there's no cookies in Dark Souls
now onwards to the giant hole I said
jump nice jump gum nice job
oh I have armor well what the [ __ ]
gorgeous I like this place my jewel ah
that's Mexican for jiggly butt cheeks
you gotta appreciate a beautiful game
when you see one
and it's definitely pretty just like my
majulah if you know what I'm saying
bonfires check bones in the sky hahahaha
holy [ __ ]
oh jesus where the hell are we going
[ __ ] am I
or in some fallen giant hope they don't
say me oh [ __ ] they see me you're super
kawaii though don't worry about bein
fire chick bones in guys
oh that corpses don't follow you anymore
goddamnit that was like one of the best
things ever hi guys it's fine it's fine
it's fine maybe that guy can help me not
why are you just sitting on god they're
everywhere
god dammit not white fog white fog going
for it going for it oh [ __ ] it was
sleeping doctor oh the white fog don't
attack me they are still attacking me
but I'm gonna go with the [ __ ] out of
here I'll go here this is safe ahh
god damn it scared me okay let's just
let's rethink our strategies here
[ __ ] hell what the [ __ ] am I doing
with my life oh [ __ ]
bye [ __ ] ah he's such package on that
went great
hahaha why are they so mean in this game
I swear in the other game there were a
little nicer to me
alright let's talk to this guy I'm sure
he's a gentleman ah HUD always hide why
did I have it to always hide oh my god
this makes such a difference
Oh what have we hit him oh god dammit is
how real men fighting dark souls and by
real men I mean [ __ ] okay you know
what I'm sorry we can't be friends
I might go here try luring it out that's
what she said haha
I don't like this I don't like this at
all
I'm out of [ __ ] ear cuz I don't like
this and I don't jump on their back no
no no no no no what nein
yes ha ha I am a little bit worried
about my health
what the [ __ ] is that
I'll stop hitting the goddamn ah I gotta
say I even though I suck ass I really
love this this is really fun to be back
in the Dark Souls alright we're doing it
the booty pie way also known as the
[ __ ] idiot way [ __ ] all of you man
gosh Jesus he's the [ __ ] that keeps
shooting me how's it no no no not today
oh god you many great knowing you guys
it's been fantastic
goddamn it can't there be a bonfire soon
this is traps everywhere in this game I
goddamn it you see you think he's taking
a [ __ ] but he actually wants to kill you
can't believe I'm doing this
[ __ ] you and your fire bombs all right
in my face
that [ __ ] what is he do with you
don't threw bombs in my face do you see
how beautiful this is not anymore
I might have [ __ ] that guy you know
what [ __ ] stop throwing them oh [ __ ] yes
friends now what the [ __ ] yes
why didn't I check you early ah bonfire
who the [ __ ] are you
ha ha don't you solve huzzah doesn't
work it seems fun down here
I like holes oh this place looks
fantastic oh I've seen this place in the
demo stop okay let's rethink this I
goddamn it okay ah stop [ __ ]
oh I hit my dog in the head what's this
hello this is a crap now we're back here
great times guys you're gonna come down
and why what am i doing the [ __ ] am i
doing I can't stop stepping Oh
I'm sure nothing bad will happen here
blood stain oh god oh god
oh okay one is dead wow so many people
died here holy [ __ ] haha
are you serious I went all this way oh
that guy doesn't look nice
take this yeah that's right he's like a
turtle but sexier how'd it feel
ugh huh ha I know this no I really
oh we're back here now ah I was hoping
for that don't don't judge me cuz I'm
ugly okay I'm usually really fabulous
I swear nice attack very good well then
what anybody then [ __ ] with that
oh you system eternal man not a mine
said hey taro man [ __ ] I don't like the
whole 1ss last thing I really like the
five estes last thing and I don't like
the have [ __ ] health thing I really
like to fall how famous climb up here
there should be a guy throwing [ __ ] here
oh god yeah I mean what is that oh [ __ ]
what is he doing
yeah yeah you know what um wrong floor
sorry I really need to kill this guy
I just don't [ __ ] know how oh [ __ ] my
ass out ah why do I have to fight so
many people oh [ __ ] I didn't mean for
that to happen
oh damn his day I didn't even have to do
anything I hope he doesn't respawn I'm
gonna cry a few respawns alright
remember what you were trained pets one
at a time baby
no I guess you call that a draw what the
fat is still there I don't know don't
don't run after me mr. kettle that's
right mr. Tuttle you'll regret it hey
Aldo Oh for [ __ ] sake one at a time
ladies one at a [ __ ] time
son of a ass [ __ ] the [ __ ] junk
oh I'm getting so [ __ ] tired of this
[ __ ] you said don't be hating I'm a
[ __ ] unicorn god [ __ ] damnit can't
even [ __ ] beat you please when you
kill a fat [ __ ] different
decided fair I have tried so hard but I
play Hello Kitty die a double they don't
even do that in school I'm a double two
now that was not a good idea I'll regret
the double hey let me drink it's your
mom's urine ha ha ah
jab not talking you don't understand
what I ever did the turtles usually
they're cute and they make weird noises
when they [ __ ] we're kind of the same
you and I you know now now you're again
now you're again
god damn it you're yet throw throw the
firebomb make something you suck so much
all right I'm gonna go through the right
voice whatever I'm gonna let some [ __ ]
oh my god 25 pussy's in my [ __ ] I'm a
[ __ ] looking for a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's not a short cut
I do quite try to believe I open a short
that girl later [ __ ] more white fog
more white fog more what [ __ ] you going
through the white foul girl going
through the white foul
No why did I say I said one dang it I've
got everything I need a black nominee
Jim now what did i do exactly why did I
do what
who touch who's touching my ass not
allowed what the hell did I just do with
my life I open gates and [ __ ] but they
don't [ __ ] go anywhere I don't know
who seen
I don't know think I don't think gate
zette I open Zaire that vet vet where
does it go
oh it's this skate it's that gate I open
sorry guys sorry James
that's adonijah all right Oh what's up
okay so hope you enjoyed leave a like if
you're dead have another wanna play one
exhales I would love to play war Dark
Souls
it's so [ __ ] [ __ ]